ich will dass sie nicht
zwei teams ein ziel berlin begleitet
unsere sechs jungen deutsch lerne rinnen
und deutsch lerne auf ihrer
abenteuerreise quer durch deutschland
entdeckt unbekannte orte und lernt
außergewöhnliche menschen kennen also
ich heiße jonas ich komme aus norwegen
ich bin 28 jahre alt ich lerne deutsch
ungefähr 99 ich würde sagen ich bin
offen
ich bin positiv und ich bin neugierig
ich bin immer wieder nach deutschland
gefahren
berlin und hamburg alter data service
geredet aber ich glaube es ist jetzt ein
bisschen anders
norwegen ist also ein ziemlich streng
island und dann dachte ich das ist cool
so durch deutschland reisen
also andere ämter als die städte da
dachte ich das will ich machen
christina so ich komme aus dem herzen
sibiriens also dicht heißt neuenbürg ich
studiere jetzt an der pädagogischen uni
deutsch studiere ich von zehn jahren
wenn ich mich nicht irre
also dann von diesem projekt habe ich
vom goethe-institut erfahre ich kann
tanzen kreativ optimistisch
menschenfreundlich das sind drei
begriffe die mit polt charakterisieren
ich bin lasse ich komme aus ägypten aus
der hauptstadt kairo
ich bin 20 jahre alt und er stegemann
ist an der pädagogischen fakultät
ich habe zwei brüder eine gute familie
zu halten
das ist mein traum eine frau zwei kinder
ein haus am meer in erster linie bin ich
ruhig und rational
ob es bereit ja es gibt immer austausch
zwischen vielen kulturen und wichtig war
die andere teilnehmer kennenzulernen
berlin
also ich bin die nicole ich bin 22 jahre
alt ich bin auf freien ich bin
jurastudenten ich bin auch
betriebswirtschaft lehrer studenten
ich glaube wohl also ich würde hoffen
dass ich einzigartig bin ich habe keine
angst ich finde immer nette leute
schrecken
ich bin auch die größte band deutschland
in australien
ich meine man kann immer nett sein aber
manchmal das greift nicht nur nett zu
sein
ich beschreibe nicht selbst nicht so
gerne aber ich würde sagen dass ich ein
sehr offener mensch bin und glücklich
also ich heiße eric samel dem motto in
kamerun
ich bin 22 jahre alt und kamera und legt
in zentralafrika also im leben bin ich
student ich studiere germanistik an der
universität mainz die deutschen wenn sie
ja sagen dann das ist wirklich ja und
wenn sie nein sagen das ist nein ich
glaube für die nächste generation müssen
wir alles tun damit sie auch gut leben
können
ich habe gesagt okay ticket nach berlin
das ist gut
hallo ich heiße suppe ich komme aus
spanien aus barcelona ich bin zwar nicht
irgendwie lustig ich studiere wwl
angenehme sich canaletto kuchen backen
was ich liebe von deutschland pünktlich
immer ich wollte er im deutsch anfangen
ich werde niemals in berlin und ich
möchte dich dort überhaupt kennen lernen
ich kann immer etwas lernen welches team
besteht die meisten herausforderungen
welches team sammelt die meisten punkte
auf dem weg in die hauptstadt
ticket nach berlin ist ein spannender
wettbewerb der deutschland aus einer
neuen perspektive zeigt
berlin
ich bin nicht blicken